[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the top 10 most
controversial opinions about the Harry
Potter series these of course are
opinions in which fans have long since
battled over since the release of the
novels throughout the making of the
films and now more than 10 years later
and since I love a good debate let's get
to it 10. body Crouch Jr was Hogwarts
best data teacher for those of you who
may need a little reminder Barty Crouch
Jr was the son of British Ministry of
magic official bharti crowned senior he
was also a loyal Death Eater who was
accused of torturing Alice and Frank
Longbottom to the point of insanity
using the cruciatus curse after Escaping
The Wizarding prison of Azkaban and
being held captive by his father for the
better part of a decade Barty Jr was
well rather insane and yet he somehow
managed to believably impersonate one of
the most skilled auras of the day
Alistair Madame moody in the role of
Hogwarts defense against a donkey's
professor and not only did bharti JR
succeed in his impersonation of Mad Eye
he was also actually really good at
teaching so much so that some fans argue
that Barty Crouch Jr as madai Moody was
actually the best defense against the
dark arts Professor that Harry and his
classmates ever had he went Above and
Beyond in the things he taught the class
and consistently seemed to guard of his
way to mentor and teach Harry's skills
such as helping him practice overcoming
the imperious curse a skill that Harry
later uses in the face of Voldemort's
attempt to make him bow of course this
opinion is quite controversial
considering Barty Jr but not only insane
but a literal murderer those who oppose
this opinion offer the idea that perhaps
Barty Crouch Jr was just a rather
skilled wizard which doesn't necessarily
translate to his ability as a professor
he also performed the three unforgivable
curses in his classroom which was not
only illegal but an endangerment to his
entire class 9. Draco Malfoy didn't
deserve his Redemption Arc particularly
in the movies Draco Malfoy is given a
story arc that attempts to redeem its
inexcusable Behavior earlier in the
series while some fans believe this Arc
is completely Justified Draco was just a
boy who'd been raised in a Prejudice
family was under the tutelage of Severus
Snape who was rather spiteful himself
bullying students and all that the other
side of this argument claims that Malfoy
is simply an arrogant git one who would
have murdered Albus Dumbledore had Snape
not stepped in the contention in this
opinion stems from whether you believe
that Malfoy was truly an evil wizard who
did nasty and unkind things to others
for sport or a misguided young man who
eventually tried to do what was right
8. Harry Potter was kind of a weenie
Harry Potter the boy who lived the
chosen one he was an incredibly Brave
young boy who embraced the fact that his
world got turned upside down at the mere
age of 11. but was he also kind of a
selfish boastful jerk in many fans
opinions he most certainly was these
fans need only to point to one of
several scenes in existence in which
Harry is wallowing in his own misery and
pushes those closest to him away yes he
was under extreme amounts of pressure
but he also never really seems to check
in on how his friends are doing with all
the chaos that surrounds them each and
every year at Hogwarts 7. Harry and
Hermione should have been a couple for
years and years fans have fought over
whether Hermione and Ron belong together
or if Miss no tall Granger should have
ended up with Harry especially in films
Hermione and Harry do seem better
matched if you're a book fan however you
know that the movie is do a poor job of
representing Ron as a well-rounded
character in comparison with the novels
even so there are still a large number
of fans who ship Harry and Hermione in
any case it all comes down to one
question really how does that tent dance
scene between Harry and Hermione in
Deathly Hallows part 1 make you feel
queasy and awkward or super pumped based
on your answer you know which side of
this controversial opinion you're on
6. Sirius Black was a poor Godfather to
Harry and to many fans of the Series
Sirius Black was the type of Loving
Family Harry never had growing up a
stark contrast to the neglectful
dursleys but was he really all that
great at being Harry's Godfather this
opinion has fans quite divided as there
are those who are Fierce supporters of
Sirius and his positive impact on
Harry's life on the opposite side of
this coin however we have fans who bring
up some valid points for starters Sirius
never made contact with Harry before
breaking into Hogwarts as a fugitive
from Azkaban you'd think he'd want to
try and warn his former best friend's
son about the dangers of Peter Pettigrew
parading around as a rat and is very
dormitory or perhaps attempt to let him
know he wasn't a mass murderer coming
for him and after they finally connect
he really wasn't around all that much
for Harry obviously he had to keep
hidden due to his fugitive status but
you'd think he would have been a touch
more present you know other than the odd
conversation through a magical fireplace
5. Neville Longbottom should have been
the chosen one this well-known opinion
is rather more of a theory than some of
the others on this list there are many
many fans who believe that Neville
Longbottom was in fact the real chosen
one that Professor Sybil triloni spoke
of in her prophecy and even if he wasn't
maybe he should have been I mean Neville
really came into his own in the end so
is it not crazy to think that he could
have made a more heroic version of the
boy who lived in my opinion he certainly
would have been a less whiny version
4. Dumbledore should have killed Tom
Riddle as a child the controversy over
this particular opinion stems from the
fact that Dumbledore would have had to
kill a child however fans argue that if
Dumbledore suspected just how evil Tom
Riddle was and how much Terror he would
bring to the world as Voldemort
shouldn't he have eliminated him as a
child when he had the chance three Alpha
Dumbledore was more evil than good it's
no secret that Albus Dumbledore spent
his youth feeling rather self-important
something he made clear in his
declaration to Harry I was gifted one
was brilliant I wanted to escape I
wanted to shine I wanted Glory I was
left with the responsibility of a
damaged sister and Wayward brother a
return to my Village in anger and
bitterness trapped and wasted I thought
as a young man with his prideful Spirit
Albus also developed a close
relationship with Gaelic Grindelwald who
went on to become one of the darkest
Wizards to have ever lived alongside
Grindelwald Dumbledore plotted had the
two could unite the three Deathly
Hallows and subjugate Muggles this
Alliance in inevitably led to an
argument between the two and albus's
brother aberforth which resulted in the
death of his ailing sister Ariana then
there's the fact that he went on to
mental Harry Potter as a child knowing
the whole time that the boy would need
to sacrifice himself and die at the
hands of Voldemort in order to overcome
and defeat him the argument against all
that of course is all the good that he
did after his choices as a Young Man and
the fact that he was simply trying to
protect the entire Wizarding World from
Voldemort exchanging the life of Harry
in order to save many two Severus Snape
was a hero one of the most divisive
opinions of the franchise is whether or
not Severus Snape was a good person a
hero for everything he did to help
Dumbledore the Order of the Phoenix and
Harry himself despite his actions that
helped take down Voldemort however
there's always the other side to this
argument that he only did so for his own
selfish reasons that his love for Lily
Evans was not enough to redeem his
qualities as bully and an incredibly
spiteful and rather cruel wizard 1. the
movies were better than the books there
are fans who will only ever read the
books Bunty will read the books and
watch the movies and those who will only
see the films no matter which group you
ask however people will always have a
fairly strong opinion on which of these
series is better and like with many film
adaptations the majority of fans seem to
say that the books are better they
included more details more backstories
and plot lines but then there are other
fans who are adamant that the movies
were actually the better of the two and
with that we've come to the end of
another video where do you sit on these
controversial topics did I miss any
controversial opinions about Harry
Potter please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel also be
sure to check out the content on Spotify
as well as extra content on my second
Channel Harry Potter Theory extra until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
foreign